hi uh I'm I Justin's iPhone and this is
my video blog um right now I'm I'm
trying really hard to
sleep but it's kind of difficult
because as you can
see she kind of like it's really
annoying and well anyway today she
dropped me on some concrete it's kind of
oh what is she doing
just please stop
it I'm kind of I'm really trying to
sleep here oh you just hit
me what are you doing why are you such a
terrible person I understand I never did
anything to you for going to treat me
this way uh I'm just kind of trying to
sleep the least you could do is just
maybe put me like on your nightstand or
something like why do I have to be near
you seriously I don't understand I just
don't understand
um anyway man I should really like set
off my alarm she's that one oh look at
that she was trying to make a call and
her
sleep oh get off of
me why why can I just not sell myself on
eBay heck I would even give myself away
for free for free if that was even
possible I would do
it please get off of
me I'm just going to set my alarm off
you ready watch this one I'll get her
I'll shut this evil
woman how do you like that how do you
like that
great well that's my entry for today
okay
bye